metro is asking for the public's help in  finding two men accused in a shooting  that happened last year at the pavilion  pool center in summerlin back on june  30th the city of las vegas rented out  the pool for what was believed to be a  family reunion it turned out to be a big  party 150 to 250 people were inside the  facility at the time police say several  altercations broke out shots were fired  in the parking lot and inside two people  had minor injuries the city then  suspended pool rentals as a result a  metro has  pursued five indictments for suspects  involved but two are still at large  michael simmons and cedric sweden both  have active arrest warrants  if you're out there turn yourselves in  if you know where they're at call crime  stoppers 385-5555  and let us know we can pick them up and  hold them responsible for what they did  here  so again if you know anything call crime  stoppers that number is  385-5555 don't forget you can remain  anonymous